Decision trees allow you to ask multiple linear questions, one after another.
So, in essence what you could do is you could first ask the question
is it windy?
Yes or no.
And by windy we define some sort of a threshold in this access over here.
Let's take this one over here because it's kind of looks the right one.
You can answer with yes or no.
And depending on what the answer is,
you will either go on this branch in the tree or this branch in the tree.
And what this effectively does is it puts a linear decision surface right here
to the diagram.
Now how can you construct this?
In one of the two outcomes, you already know the final class,
which one would you know be done with, and you have the right answer.